hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 80 of game
programming we have hit 80 episodes so
that that deserves a like right there
but um freakin episode 80 that is that's
quite a lot of episodes so I'm happy
that you guys stuck with me thus far if
you have of course you have a new strand
I clicked on it and hopefully will be
wrapping up the game in less than
another 8 episodes but we'll see anyway
we're gonna talk about better particle
animation essentially today so we're
gonna be adding a Zed variable to this
I've got X Y we're gonna talk about Z
today so let's just take a look quickly
what we have right now so if we just
launch particle they kind of just
explode everywhere and you can see that
it doesn't really feel like gravity's
involved at all in this and we want to
basically add this concept of gravity we
want to simulate some really basic
physics here so how are we gonna do that
well we're gonna add a Z modifier here
like I said um a Z Direction essentially
for it to go now the way that this is
currently um laid out is fine but I'm
gonna change that so what I'm gonna do
is I'm actually gonna keep the xx YY
heal and then I'm just gonna make
another line for protected double X a
and y ok and the reason for that is I'm
now gonna add said Z and Z a and it just
was it was just becoming a pretty big
line it was kind of unorganized so I
like to organize things at least in
programming so I split it up into two
lines here okay so what do we do with
said currently we've got this sort y is
equal to random dot next Gaussian we're
gonna set this dot Z Z equal true let's
just set it to 2.0 right now okay and
we'll probably set it to a random value
as soon as I demonstrate this so what we
want to do now the idea is of course to
simulate Z the best way to do that if we
want to add some kind of gravity now if
we just launched our game right now even
though it is technically top-down the
way the people are going to see gravity
at least for now is gonna be downwards
okay so what we want to do is we want to
kind of move
these particles down now the first thing
you're gonna ask is okay well this is a
2d egg okay this is a 2-d game how are
we gonna move them down well how would
you move them down you would move them
in the positive y-direction wouldn't you
okay so because of that because we want
to move them in the positive y-direction
here all we're gonna do is actually go
over here and into our render and we're
going to actually subtract cut class to
an integer first Zed Zed from our YY
okay and what that's gonna do is move it
downloads for us so the way that we're
actually going to do that is over here
in our this dot xx and this dot YY we
add X a and Y a tour which is basically
the amount of animation we want to add
to it we're gonna do the exact same for
Z so this does it Zed Zed plus equals Z
a okay and zedenka isn't currently set
to anything okay that's one thing that
you should probably have noticed and
that's absolutely fine okay
so a lot of questions are circulating in
your mind first of all why are we
subtracting Zed Zed are not adding a Zed
Zed and the second question is what is
going on with Z a I'll talk about that
in a minute but if we just preview this
as it is right now you can see that our
particles don't change at all
which is good okay and the reason they
don't change is elder's lot of reasons
primarily because of course Zed says is
just statically equal to two so all
we're doing is we're simply we're simply
subtracting two from our Y rendering
location but what we're going to do now
is actually animate this value of Z a
what we're gonna do is for X a we're
going to subtract sorry for Z a we're
going to subtract 0.1 from it every
frame okay rather not frame every update
okay or every tick we're gonna subtract
the arrow point one so what's that what
that's gonna do if I just bring up Altaf
old paint old man here old and rusty
paint on that what's gonna happen is
currently um za is equal to zero again
that's the default
if I grab a paintbrush here this is
probably not a wide enough that's
probably good okay so if I grab this
paintbrush here and I'll show you what I
mean if we're at zero right if we're
subtracting zero from Y or in this case
I guess what subtracting two from Y but
anyway if if CA is zero what sort of
going like that now as soon as Z a
starts to decrease so does our line here
and of course since we're subtracting
zero point one at this point in time our
rate might be zero point one because
we've just subtracted at one frame now
next frame it'll be zero point two and
by frame are really mean updates sorry
and so on so it's actually going to not
really exponentially but the rate at
which it decreases is actually going to
increase so we might have a zero point
three here and eventually we'll have
something like one and we'll keep going
further and further okay so that's sort
of how this whole thing works so what
we're doing is instead of just going all
okay let's just make a linear we're
actually creating a curve here and
that's just gonna look a lot better okay
so I hope you guys enjoy that
the ATF's so it's special that little
diagram there so let's take a look at
what this looks like now if we launch
this and run this Oh check that out
we've got some kind of sick gravity
simulation going here now just to show
you guys what it would be like if it was
linear if we just set this equal to zero
point four for example and run this
that's probably not even good enough
make sure it's negative first of all and
then let's set it to about 1.4 you can
see we just get this kind of linear like
it just doesn't look nice because these
particles are just going down down a
linear path they don't have any they
don't have anything interesting about
them they're boring
okay but if we actually do subtract
their from one we're actually changing
the rate at which it goes down every
update
and we get something a lot more
interesting and just more aesthetically
pleasing and you can say that the speed
at which they go down sort of increases
the further that they go so that's a
really cool thing that we just added
what we're gonna talk about next is
simulating a floor so we want to
simulate a floor now the reason is this
is this looks just kind of really cool
first of all but kind of unrealistic
right because what's happening is it's
just falling off the screen as if it's
not even part of the level it just looks
cool but this would be cool for a
platform or something a platformer but
it just doesn't really work for a
top-down top-down game especially cuz
it's going all over the walls and it's
just doesn't really fit in although it
is very cool okay that's that's what it
has going for it now that changed that
we're gonna add a floor okay now think
about it if Zed Zed is our like a
virtual said coordinates so in other
words X is horizontal of course Y is
vertical for us and Zed is kind of our
depth here if you look at the if you
look at it from a top-down set is our
depth now if we're simulating depth here
the floor should be at around Z equals
zero right so let's just say that the
floors of Z equals zero and the more we
increase that the closer is to the
camera and the more we decrease it the
further is away from the camera so kind
of like OpenGL here because that's how
that's sort of close to the camera is
actually a positive Z direction although
in my opinion it should probably be the
other way around was that the further
you push it back and said that actually
the the bigger the number is but anyway
so basically what we want to do now is
create a floor a virtual floor and to do
that we're gonna say that okay well if Z
equals zero then our particles are on
the floor so let's make them bounce this
is gonna be cool so right over here
we'll simply say that if Zed Zed if this
does that Zed and I'm really there's no
need to put this here because um there
is no set set local variable here if Zed
Zed is a less than zero or equal to zero
whose mental less than zero
definitely matter because there's
probably never going to be equal to zero
because of this subtraction
if says it is equal to zero first of all
we don't want particles to go beneath
the floor so let's make sure that they
can't be less than zero by setting them
equal to zero if they are less than zero
and the other thing that we'll do is
simply change the direction of them okay
that's very simple to do now and will
probably slow them down a heap now if
this is going down okay let me just
explain this thing as well this is of
course becoming negative Z a starts at
the default value of zero as we subtract
things za is a negative value so it
becomes negative zero point one then
next update it began it becomes negative
zero point two then negative zero point
three etc because we're subtracting a
zero point one every update now clearly
because YY is a positive value here and
we're subtracting said said which is a
negative value okay since of course that
Z is actually plus equal set a which
means that every every tick every update
where in this case we're actually adding
a negative zero point one to it then
next update we'll add negative zero
point two negative zero point three
point four etc this will be negative
essentially and because we're going
negative negative we're adding ok so
eventually we'll be doing stead of going
YY minus negative one for example we're
going YY plus negative one because of
course if you add a negative if you
subtract a negative number that's going
to be an addition so that's why we do
put a negative here not a positive
because of course if you think logically
this should be a positive if Z Zed was a
positive number and we wanted to go down
without a positive but because it's
negative we got a chuck in a negative so
of course back to this floor thing if Z
Zed is less than zero let's make sure
that doesn't go beneath the floor and
let's reverse it's like it's direction
and we can do that really simply just by
saying Z a x equals negative 1 how do we
make a negative number positive we
multiply it by negative 1 how do we make
a positive number negative we multiply
by negative 1 same thing right so that's
this is some really basic maths here now
the idea though is that when particle
when something bounces off the floor
it's pretty rare that it actually
bounces off with the same velocity
usually slows down but let's take a look
at what this looks like anyway just for
fun you can see that as soon as I hit
the ground which is very fast obviously
because we said that is only equal to
two if we if we said there's something
too if we set this like something like
20 then um they'll be a little higher
but you can see that bounce is really
pronounced now yeah but the problem here
is let me just quickly fix one thing
this sum in projectile sorry in wizzard
projectile the life of this is set to 44
right now I'm gonna set it to 440 just
so we can see this without it
disappearing let's go back into particle
okay so if we look at this you can see
that how you can see them bouncing and
it's really pronounced here right but
the thing is they bounce up with the
same velocity - they bounce down that's
a bit of a problem for us isn't it we
kind of want them to slow down so what
we'll do is instead of multiplying it by
negative one we can multiply it by
something that's less than one so
something that's between zero and
negative one so point five might be a
good place to start right in the middle
so if we take a look at this what we
should see is they slow down and they
slow down really quickly in fact you can
see that after two bounces their base
pitchers start sliding maybe set it to
something like zero point eight and this
is where different materials come in if
these were wood particles we might want
them to bounce a bit if they were stone
particles we really might want them not
to okay so that's a really cool way to
do it now
the thing is we're slowing down Zed now
okay so they bounce you can see that
their bounces get less and less high
that's cool but you can see they really
do scatter a lot on the X and the y axis
that's probably not a good thing because
we kind of want them to slow down a bit
and of course we can do that just as we
were before with every bounce let's have
the rate at which they go across the
x-axis and let's have the rate at which
they go across the y-axis
now you could divide equal this by two
and really you'd get the same effect but
some it's just better sand multi-use
multiplication or than division mmm
that's just how I roll okay so there we
go you can see that as they go there
they sort of stop yeah and they kind of
keep bouncing here they will eventually
stop and you can see they stopped around
the time that they disappear but that's
pretty much how that works okay
very very simple very effective this is
probably too fast if we put it to zero
point to that belly move it all probably
yeah you see they kind of as soon as
they hit the ground they kind of stop at
that place and they stop bouncing maybe
something like point four might be fine
you can actually vary these of course
you can maybe say oh okay let's not make
the move almost at all on the x-axis but
let's make the move a fair bit on the
y-axis so they'll kind of be spread out
top down as you can see there they kind
of stretch across the y-axis I'm
probably going to leave them in about
point four you guys can decide what you
want for yourselves but um that looks
pretty good
okay now the only thing wrong about this
is the life but that's all right let's
set this some let's set this back to
something like point five and what
you'll see is they'll actually stop
after a while and I really like that to
be honest I kind of want the particles
to top you and in fact this life is fine
because after a while they'll disappear
but they lived a good life now what you
might be thinking is well a lot of
things are probably going through your
head first of all this is awesome I'm
going to use this all the time but the
other thing is what about this Walsh
owner they're going through the wall
that's not realistic at all now we could
use some pretty a lot some relatively
basic physics here to actually make the
mounts off the wall or we could just say
that okay if we hit a wall from the left
side let's not make sure that the X can
be negative of course this way going
left is a negative x direction so all we
really need to do here is say okay well
if the wall is a par is on the left side
here if we hit the if the projectile
travels this way and it hits the wall
which is on the left side then let's not
let's make sure that X a which is the
amount which is the amount by which X X
by which X X increases every tick every
update let's make sure that that value
b-negative so at the moment x.i is set
to random nom next course in which gives
it a massive distribution here with a
main of sura point zero it gives it a
pretty big distribution let's add let's
add about two point zero to X a and
let's see what that looks like now so
now we've added on to point zero so it
should essentially only go positive here
and you can see it does it kind of there
are still a few particles that don't
really you're one that goes back here
because I'm around them again as I said
around random little next course and
doesn't exactly give you a value between
between what was it negative 1 and 1 it
doesn't really do that so it gives you
quite a random distribution but you can
see that's roughly what what's happening
so maybe let's let's add about 2.5 to
this little also and as we do that you
can see that we are a really birthday on
the wrong place here to let some adjust
for the X here by subtracting around 14
pixels I don't know that's just I'm off
the top of my head so what that looks
like and that's almost good maybe about
12 okay that's looking pretty good there
are still the off the odd pixel that do
go backwards but in fact I think that's
probably a bit too much less maybe drop
this to about a 1.8 or so let's check
that out
yeah so I'm I'm relatively happy with
that distribution now let's let's
account for these particles that are
built behind the wall by saying that if
this dot X a is actually less than 0 so
in other words if it can be negative
let's just set it equal to 0.1 so they
go forward a bit all right a bit and
that'll get rid of all those particles
that were going behind as you can see so
that looks pretty realistic now apart
from the fact that while we're getting
around in particles and they are taking
forever to disappear but of course they
will slowly disappear and when they do
it looks really cool but let's quickly
fix up one thing first will be height at
which they fall is 20 right now that's
cool let's maybe randomize it a bit
let's set it
next float and maybe add about 2.0 or so
so let's take a look at that okay there
we go
so now this looks more like um stone
right because this is what I was going
for by the way this kind of looks more
like stone because what's happening here
is um well we are hitting essentially a
stone wall and this kinda looks like
stone it doesn't bounce much doesn't
move much just kind of crumples on us if
you really wanted to crumple you could
probably decrease this even more but
I'll probably set it to about 0.7 so we
get a little bit of bouncing going on
and you can see that's probably a bit
too much
5 5 maybe check that out
that looks pretty that looks really good
I'm really happy that looks like so
that's great so let's go back to our
wizard projectile clasp real quick set
this back to 44 and see what it looks
like we have the quick disappearance and
look at that wonderful so that is what
our particles look like right now there
are a few things I wanted to mention
since it is episode 80 and that's well
calls for calls for a few announcements
first of all what you're seeing right
now is the game that I made during the
27th lld competition a lot of damn and
as you can see the graphics look really
nice now that's because I made them in
After Effects and of course I didn't
make them during the competition if you
watch my live stream you can see that
and in fact if you check out the
time-lapse you can see me roughly making
them as well I'm probably going to make
those kind of sprites for this game ok
because I I just want to step off this
game graphically now there are you guys
have two options here I could either
show this as episodes of this series and
otherwise show you guys me making these
sprites or I could just make them and
you know basically replace them behind
scenes so not showing the one on video
if you want me to see if you actually
want to see me making these sprites let
me know in the comments okay and I'll be
looking for like a top comment or a up B
amount of comments essentially should
say yes show no show us how you make
those sprites or of course I could just
make them in my own time and then show
the next episode and focus on
programming rather than an asset
creation but if you do want to see them
let me know and of course I will um I'll
show you guys the process the go behind
doing that and I'll make them in front
of you guys so I'll comment and do
everything as it was in the Norton
normal episode of game programming but
um far from that guys thank you for
watching thank you for all of you who
have stuck through 80 episodes of me
talking about this and showing you guys
how to make games it's taught me a lot
and yeah I'm really thankful that I have
sixteen thousand five hundred plus
people to teach how to UM how to make
games so yeah thanks a lot guys goodbye
you
you